これからあの まあこの紹介の続きとして話を始まります
あの人間の判断ということについて
今日のテーマを持っていきたいと思います
今日は時間短いですので
あの あまりこの何でしたっけ？寄り道をしないで
直接ポイントだけ言って終了いたします
もしわからないところがあったら
後でテープでも聞いて考えてください
あの時々私にも 仏教のことをよく喋ったりするんだから
このいろんな問題で悩んでいる人々が
もうこの場合はどうすればいいんですかと聞いたりする時もあります
で まあ私にこのちゃんとしたこの判断を欲しがっちゃうんですね
で 大体私はその場合はあまり答えないんです
で なぜかというと まあこういう問題あるんだけど
どうすればいいんですかと
聞く人が結局自分でやりたいことは心の中でもちゃんとあるんですよ
例えば人間関係のトラブルで
なんとか人がこういう風に言いますし
こういうこういう問題を作ってるし
どうすればいいんですかと
で 聞いても本当は答えを聞きたくないんですよ
で 自分で決まってる判断は実行する
あの 何て言いますか 勇気がなくて
で 私に先生もそう言ったんだからといって
それでまあやりたいと
それでなんで私は答えないかというと
大体人々っていうのは
何か問題に出会ったら
あの 自分では答えを持ってるんですよ
その答えはなぜ実行できないかというと
このいつでも自分では相手を相手に勝ちたいと
相手を負かせたいんだと
という気持ちがあるんですね
相手を潰したいんだと
自分の意見をとにかく主張したいんだと
母親が子供について私に相談したっても
気持ちは自分の気持ち
自分の考え方 それはとにかく子供に押し付けたいんですね
それはどうすればいいんですか？と聞くんですよ
そういう風には本当は聞かないんです
本当は色々トラブルがあって
まあこういうこういうことなんですけど
どうすればいいんですかと
言葉上では問題ないんですよ
言葉上では問題ないんだけど
心の中ではやっぱり自分の気持ち
自分の考え方 自分の希望
欲望によって相手を管理したい
支配したいという気持ちがはっきりとあるんですね
だから答えてあげても意味がない
理解しようとしない で
普通のカウンセリングだったら
まあそうですねと言って
なんか褒めてあげればね
さすがお母さんの考え方
あなたの考え方はまあちゃんと理屈通ってるんだよと
その通りだよと言ってあげれば
すごい機嫌が良くなって
またその相手の人をもう抑えて抑えようとするだけであって
正しいことにはならないんですね
正しい良い結果には結果が得られなくなっちゃうんですね
だから最初にそこは気をつけてほしいんですね
我々はいろんな問題について判断を迫られた時は
結局私たちはいつでも自分の意見
とにかく通してほしい
それは心の中にあるんですよ
でも表では言えないんですね
で それでトラブルが起きたりするんですよ
だから判断の問題で我々はよく考えてほしいのは
ご自分たちで じゃあこの問題として
正直 自分の正直な気持ちでどういう答えですかと
それは何かあるはずなんですね
じゃあ自分のこの正直な気持ちっていうのはどんなものかと
それはいいものか悪いものかと
それから客観的に考えてみればいいんですよ
例えば会社の同時の相談があるんですね
どちら側も自分が儲かりたいという
気持ちは正直なんですよ
それを抑えておいて ただ上辺だけで
この世の中にはこういうこういう商売は大変いいですよと何とか言うんですね
でもそれであまり相談は成立しなくなっちゃうんです
それで相手の反論に答えられなくなった時は
やっぱりどういう風にすればいいんだよ
どういう風にすればいいんですか？とかね
で また考えたり悩んだりする
ですから この このいろんな判断に悩んでいる人々っていうのは
あの よく見られることっていうのは
自分ではもう初めからもう研究もしないで
勉強もしないで もう初めからもうもう答え持っていることなんですね
ですから 皆様にもそういう経験あるだろうと思いますけど
人の相談に乗ってみたら
まあどうしようもないお手上げ状態なんですよ
話は聞かないんですね
で せっかく相談に乗るということは
話を聞くためでしょうに
だから最終的には何しに来たんですか？と聞きたくなるところまで
相手とは話してはいるんだけど
やっぱりどれでも自己主張で
自分の考え方だけとにかく持っていきたくなるんですね
ですから この人間になぜ判断できないかというと
そこは問題なんですね
自分の意見というのはものすごい厳密に持っているんですね
それはもう自己主張であってわがままなんですね
だから英語ではワンサイダー一つの側面しか見てないんですね
だから この人間になぜ物事にすべて正しい判断できないかというと
いつでもそうやってワンサイダーで自分の方しか知らない
で 問題はもうだから理解できない
自分の気持ち 自分の感情
その中でもうぐるぐるぐるぐる回っているんであって
問題っていうのは自分の感情の中にあるものじゃなくて
やっぱりもう一人と外の世界との関わりなんですよ
だからまあ 外の世界の関わりだから
まあそれは考えないで
頭の心の中だけでぐるぐる回ったっても意味がないんですよ
それは雷は怖いだと思って
耳に指を刺しても 雷落ちだったら死んじゃいますよ
それだけで問題は解決しないんですね
自分の心の中から見れば
まあ音は怖いというぐらいかもしれませんだけど
雷はざーざーと落ちるところであるならば
やっぱり雷は怖いと だから目も閉じて耳も塞いておく
それで安全ですかと それで安全なわけじゃないんです
自分の気持ちだけ落ち着けばいいわけじゃないんです
問題は外にあるんですよ
ですから もう雷が怖いんだったら
雷が落ちてくるんだったら
雷が落ちない場所に自分が逃げなくちゃいけないんですね
それが答えなのに 目を閉じることで問題解決しようかなと
ですから この大体世の中のいろいろ問題
トラブルが起きちゃうと
我々は自分の心の中だけで考えて
ものすごくわがままで自己主張主義で
自分の意見のみ通してほしいと思う
それは自分にとって は気持ちいいんですよ
だから自分の気持ち 自分に気持ちいいということは問題に答えですかと
私は機嫌がいいんだと
こういう風になったらという
それで答えにならないんですよ
だから世の中でみんな生きてる上では
いつでもどのように生きているかというと
自分の気持ちよければいいんだと
自分の機嫌が良ければそれでいいやということで生きていようとするんですよ
だから一つも世の中で人間というのは問題は解決しないんです
今までの人類の歴史を見てみても
いろんな問題 しょっちゅう毎日朝
朝も晩もいろいろ起きてくるんだけど
一つも解決するということはないんです
なんかあっちこっち あっちこっち
もうごまかしごまかしをしながら
なんとか生きているだけなんですね
だから世の中に一向に平和というものはないし
もう社会の問題っていうのは一向に解決したわけじゃないんですよ
でも ずっと人類が現れた時からも同じ問題考えているんですよ
子ども育てはどうしますか？社会の安定はどうしますか？経済的な安定はどうしますかとかね
家族はどうしますか？とかね
人間関係どうしましょうか
そうやっても ありとあらゆる問題
同じ問題なんですよ  2000年前にも
3000年前にも 今の時代でも
これからもあるのは そこまで考えて考えてきたのに
いまだに答えがないんです
どんな問題に 例えば夫婦を夫婦が喧嘩しないようにと
それ具体的に我々のある問題なんですね
だから 男と女が一緒に生活するということは
人間が現れた時からも来たことでしょうに
やってきたことでしょうに
いまだにそのノウハウ
テクニックを持っていないんです
いまだに 今はもっとひどいんですよ
3年ごとに離婚して再婚する
再婚するようになってるんだから
アメリカなんかのいろいろ情報を見ちゃうと
まあ半年間でもう離婚と
また2週間でまた他の人と結婚して
また1年で離婚と だからもっとひどくなってるんですよ
夫婦で仲良く生活する技はいまだに知らない
だから この人類はずっと昔から何を勉強して
何を理解してきたんですかというと
何も理解していないんです
それは皆様の社会を見ると
皆様はよく理解できると思います
例えば 教育制度の中でいろいろ問題が起きたりする
子供たちがいろいろ問題起きたりする
学校を拒否したりする
教育も拒否したりする
あるいはもう勉強したものは役に立たなくなったりとか
いろいろ問題がある で
それでもう知識人たちが集めて
やっぱり教育制度を変えなくちゃいけないんだとかね
それで何年も研究して
何年も調べて レポートでは答えはなしという
例えば学校はこの6日そう
じゃあいつか制度にしようかと
いわゆる一つの結論のようなものなんですけど
いまだに実行は不可能だと
ということは あれは答えじゃないということなんですね
でも もともとも6日制度はちょっと子供には負担がありすぎやという前提で始めた考え方なんですけど
もう同じところに戻っちゃうんですね
ということは 何一つも理解しようとしないんですよ
ただ 雷が怖いんだったら
もう耳に指を刺せばいいんだと
それぐらいの答えで で
なんとかこのからくりやろうとしているだけなんですね
だから その理由は 人間っていうのは
自分の気持ちよければいいという
立場にいるんです だから
例えば警察を管理するために
エリートの人々 何人かの組織があるとするとありますでしょうに
それだったら そちらの仕事は客観的に
国民の立場から見て どのようにより良い安全な社会を作ろうかと
どのように 警察も人間だからね
どうせ間違いを起こすし
どのように管理すればいいかということはチェックすることですが
でもそういうことはしないで
まあ自分が偉い立場にいるんだからね
それで機嫌が良くて 気持ちよくて
その自分の気持ちいい状況を守ることしか考えないんですよ
役に立たない 国の政治家が
例えば総理大臣になったら
これえらいかっこいいんですよ
かなり立場がありまして
すべての権限は自分で持っていて
国会解散するなりに招集するなりに
選挙を興すなりに 何でも自分がもう判断する
気持ちいいんですよ それで
あ この気持ちいい立場をどのようにすれば守られるかと
それしか考えないんですよ
だから問題が起きちゃったら
もう誰か書いたメモを読むだけ
問題に答えを持っていないんです
そういうことで 世の中で
まあいろんな国々で まあ私は国民を救済して解放してあげるぞという偉そうなことを言って政治家になる人々いるんだけど
一向に一人も国民のために何もやってくれない
だから政治家が悪いだけじゃなくて
すべての人間というのはそんなもんなんです
ですから 具体的に客観的に世の中を見ると
人間というのは何一つも
毎日出会う問題に解決方法を持ってないんですね
わからないんですよ 例えば
若いお母さんが自分の子供のいろいろ問題解決することできなくなっちゃって
お母さんに聞く 自分のお母さんに
あるいは旦那のお母さんに聞く
どうすればいいんですかと
答えを持っていないんです
自分が先輩なのに 自分も子供育て大きくしたのに
やり方わからない ですから
このどう生きるべきかと
問題にどう対応するべきかということは
どんな先輩に聞いても全然もう頼りにならないだろうと思います
で それはおかしいと思うならば
自分の心に聞いてみてください
ご自分 皆様方に自信ありますかね？若い人々はちゃんとリードして
ガイドして導く自信がありますか？これは正しくて
こういう風にやって こういう風にやって生きてみなさいよと
ぴったし成功するよと
自分の子供が何か問題に遭った時に
自分に相談に乗る 両親にちゃんと答えられますかね
先輩として 人生の経験がある人として
ですから 自分の心に聞いてみてください
自分に自信がありますかと
若者を育てる自信が 任せておけと
私は年上ですよと もう経験済みですよと
でないだろうと思います
そんなもんなんです ですから
私たちは先輩に頼ったっても同じことで
我々の後輩たちと我々に頼ったっても
我々も何の頼りにもならない
いい加減中途半端な考え方で生きているんですね
どこにこの中途半端さが生まれてくるかというと
我々の心の中で自分の機嫌さえ良ければいいんだと思ってるんですよ
だから答えは簡単ですよ
世の中っていうのは この私の機嫌という軸に回っているわけじゃないんだと
問題っていうのは外にあるんだと
ですから この自分の気持ちということをね
それはもうわがままで
我が強いということ エゴですね
ですから この我々の心は自分の中に入ってるんですよ
外を見てないんです だから外から何を触れるかとわからないんです
まあまあ 大体まあそういうことで何か理解できるだろうと思いますけどね
ですから この 自分の気持ち
自分の好みというものはね
置いといて 外に問題を持ってきて
いわゆる私はよく言う
この客観性ですね 客観的に何でも見るならば
すべての問題にはすぐ瞬時に答えが出てくるんですよ
ですから 自分の問題についても
それも自分自身を客観化すれば
一切の問題は解決するというのは
仏教のまあずっと言っている立場なんですよ
だから宗教とは正反対かもしれません
宗教というのはあくまでも主観で
主観で 哲学的にしゃべろうしゃべろうと言ってますけどね
で 仏教は主観を捨てろと
それ自体間違ってるんだと
物事は客観的に見ましょうと
主観というのはありえないんだと
主観というのはありえないんですよ
よく考えてください 自分には自分の意見というものが何かあるんですかと
我が強い頭が悪い人々は堂々と言うかもしれません
ありますよと言ったっても
ちょっと環境変わっちゃえば
その意見はもうぐるっと変わっちゃうんです
例えば 私は人間として立派で
なかなか怒りませんと
まあどんな問題あったって
私はもう怒りませんよとかいう
まあまあ もうもうこれはもう今もう 50歳ですよと
いまだにもう全然怒ったことはないんですよ
言っても ちょっと条件変えてあげてください
何か言ってみてください
怒るか怒らないかと 怒り出しますよ
だから我々は笑うなりに笑って明るい人生をしているんですか？あるいは暗くて文句ばっかり言う暗い人生か
あるいは怒りっぽくて
もうそういう苛立ちだけの人生かと
あるいはアホで何でも失敗する
何でも壊す 何でももうむちゃくちゃに邪魔にしてしまう
もう無知的な人生かとかね
そういうものはすべて自分ということじゃなくて
やっぱり外の影響から出てくるんですよ
だから主観っていうのはもともともないもんなんですよ
で 外から帰って入ってくる情報が自分の心の中に
そこで処理して何かを何かを反応する
だからそれ自体が私のもの
私の考え方 私の意見 私の生き方と思うと
その人は仏教で言うのおろか者ということなんです
私の意見というのはありっこはない
私の気持ちっていうのはもうないんです
その気持ちはすぐ変えてしまっちゃいますから
変わってしまっちゃいますから
ちょっと環境が変わっただけで
そういうことだから このあまりにも私たちはこの自分のものでない
ものを自分のものやとものすごくしがみついているんだから
一向に問題っていうのは解決しないんですよ
じゃああの それは一応あの
今日のテーマの答えでありまして
それに付け加えていろいろポイントを考えてみましょう
で 世の中でこの もしかするといろいろ問題が起きた場合は
この完璧に正しい答えっていうのは
あり得るんでしょうかと
大体は完璧に正しいという答えはないかもしれません
ある場合もありますけど
ない可能性は多いんですよ
だから物事っていうのはその場でその場でできるものだから
次にどんなことになるかっていうことはわからないんです
だから我々は大体トラブルを起こす一つの原因というのは
一番正しい答えというか
完璧な完全な答えを探そうとしてるんですね
この完全な答え 完全なものを探しているんだから
一向に見つからない それでまた自分の主観がまたものすごく揺れてしまって
もう苦しみになってしまっちゃうんです
結婚するために完璧な相手を探す
完璧な相手を探す人は一生結婚できなくなっちゃうんです
結婚しても不幸になっちゃうんです
だから完璧な答えがないんですよ
そこら辺理解すれば 我々には完全に納得できることは何一つもないんだと
ありえないんだと  どこかで手を打たなくちゃいけないんですよ
それはすべて人生はそういうふうになっているんです
じゃあそこら辺で手を打ちましょうと
お見合い写真いっぱい持ってきて
まあ一つ選ぼうと思ったら
女の子だったらこれもダメ
これもダメ これもダメ
これもダメ そういう性格だったら
世界中のすべての男の写真を持ってきたっても
すべてダメになっちゃうんですね
だからまあそこそこで
まあまあこれぐらいでいいんじゃないかなと
そのどこかで手を打つ気持ち
考え方 それを持っていくと
かなり軽々く生きていられると思います
それはなかなかない できんやらないんですね
子供が生まれてきたら
もう完璧な子供になってほしいと
それは恐ろしいわがままなんですね
恐ろしい自己満足なんですね
自分の満足のために子供をずっといじめてやるぞという
でも口で言うのは あなたは立派な人間にしてあげたいんだから
お母さんもお父さんもそう頑張っているんだと
それは立派な人間にしたいんではなくて
あれはこの人の肉を食うような感じでいう恐ろしいこの行動なんですよ
人食い人間なんですよ
ですから 完璧な子供を育てると思う場合は
大体九十九パーセント失敗するでしょうに
だからどこかで手を打たなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 完璧な教師もいませんし
完璧な子供もいませんし
完璧な母もいませんし
完璧な父親もいませんし
完璧な家庭もいません
ありません 完璧な社長も完璧な社員も世の中ではいません
よくも他人にこの完全性を認めること
そうそう接する恐ろしい考え方なんですよ
自分がだらしなくて ろくでもない生き方をしながら
相手に完全性を認める
相手が完全でなければ腹が立つ
そういう生き方ではどんな問題も解決できるわけじゃないんです
ただ単に問題を作るばっかりで
次から次へと問題を作る
だから嫌な繊細になっちゃうんですよ
一人のそういうふうな人が来たら
もう次に問題を作る それを何とかして
また次に問題を作る それを何とかすると
また次にまた問題を作っちゃう
このトラブルだけの みんなに迷惑だけかける
頭が悩ませることばっかりする人々もいるでしょうに
それはこの他人に対して完全性を認める
時々恐ろしい子供たちいるでしょ
親に暴力振るうは もう学校で暴力振るうは
もう言うことを聞かないわ
不良に走るわとかね なんでそうなったんですか？と
母が悪かったと 平気で言うでしょうね
学校の先生悪かったと
自分が何なのかと それは見ようとしない
自分が不良に走ることは
それは放っておけと それは放っておけ
でも母が悪かったと 母が厳しかったんだから
私は自由を探す 探して
自分でやりたい放題やるんだと
でも母がやりたい放題やるのは
それはダメですよと 母が奴隷みたく子供の言うことを全部聞いてあげなくちゃいけないんだと
そういう考え方でしょうに
だから人がだらしなければないほど
他人に完璧になれと 完全になれと命令する
希望する 脅迫する いろんなことをします
ですから この 正しい答えっていうのは
世の中では成り立たない
ありえないんです ですから
この心の中に この他人に
厳しく完全性を認めることをやめた方がいいんです
よく世の中であることなんですけど
ですから あの もし何か問題があったとする
その問題に何か我々は答えを出したりする
その答え自体は完璧というわけじゃないんですよ
だから我々はベタというね
まあまあ まあまあ これぐらいの答えでいいんじゃないかなと
というぐらいのレベルの答えを出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
答えはこれですと ２足す２でしょ
だから４ですと ５にはなりませんと
そういうふうには人生は成り立ちません
ですから あの まあこれぐらいでしょうと
という答えは出す そこで出した答えも次にうまくいかない時もあります
なぜならば完璧な答えじゃないんだから
条件変わると まあ自分出した結論も合わない時もあります
それで答えを出した人が
決めた人が正しく決めたならば
じゃあ調整しましょう
では変えましょうと だから我々は決めたものでも常に調整する必要があります
それにいろんなところを変える必要があります
これこそということじゃないんです
で 世の中で一つ問題っていうのは
私がそう決めたんだからやりなさいよと
ものすごい頑固で言う人々がいるでしょうに
これは命令だから 社長命令だから
そうやって決めたんだから
会議で決めたんだから
だから結果どうであろうと
もう TPO も何も考えないで実行しようとする
実行させようとする そういう頑固様
何なのかと それはまあ
本人はやっぱり自分の判断
自分の命令 完璧だと 完全だと思っているんだからなんですよ
まあ一応こういうことだよというふうに判断すれば
その TPO に応じて そのオケージョンに
その場所に その時間に応じて
あ やっぱりちょっと調整した方がいいんじゃないかな
だから 人にはまず決断
判断できないにも関わらずする
した決断判断には頑固と執着してとらわれて
変化は認めない 評価しない
許さない もうアホのいいところなんですよ
例えば 簡単な例で言うならば
まあ子供は毎日学校に行くべきですよ
でも熱出したり病気になっちゃったら
家で休んだ方がいいでしょうに
それは当たり前のことで
毎日学校に行くべきです
だから 言葉だけに引っかかってたら
毎日学校に行くべきですよと言ったら
もうたとえ熱が出ても
だからそんなぐらいでもうちゃんと学校に行きなさいということになっちゃうんですね
だから そういうのはいつでも変化しなくちゃいけないんですよ
調整しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 必ずも学校に行くべきですかと
義務教育だから そうでもないんでしょうに
自分一人で他の方法で勉強するんだったら
勉強して試験だけ受かればそれでも十分でしょうに
そういうことだから この必ずもそうでなくてはならないということはね
大変問題なんですよ 例えば日本だったら
大学だったら あの なかなかいくら天才の子供であろうか
10歳で 15歳では入れませんね
小学校 中学校の勉強っていうのは
例えば一年で終わってしまったと
でもダメです ちゃんと学校に行かなくちゃいけないんです
行かなかったら卒業しません
できませんと 高校を卒業してないんだから
年数稼いで これぐらいこれはあんた教育を受けてないんだから
まあ大学の入学は拒否するんだと
というあまりにも無知的で
あまりにも頑固なんですね
その特別なケースもありますよと
ということはないんです
ということで この決めたんだからこうということではないんですよ
正しく決めた人が正しく決めたということは
完璧な答えを出したわけではないんですよ
より良い答えを出すということなんです
それは正しい判断なんです
出した人はいつでも  この場合はこうしましょう
この場合こうしましょうというふうな調整はする
だから瞑想をなさっている方々もにもよく言いますけどね
で 基本はこういう基本なんだけど
ずっと調整しなくちゃいけないんだと
でもみんなもうどこかである決まりにはまってしまって
あるしきたりにはまってしまって
それだけでぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる回りたいんですね
だからなかなか成功しない
それは身をもって経験させているはずなんですけど
それぞれなりにそれなりに調整して
調整して調整して 前へ前へ前へ進むようにしなさいと
だから この性格の悪さ
この頑固さっていうのをはっきりと体験できるんですよ
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でもやってみたら
それはどんな人間にもある問題で
だから世の中っていうのは問題だらけで
答え一つもないような世の中になっているんですね
ですから この この今日の今言ったポイントっていうのは
我々にはいつでもこの訂正する能力
調整する能力 それは大変立派なことなんです
生き方においても 勉強においても
仕事においても どんなものにおいても
自分が判断するんですが
自分が決めたことでも何でもいいんだけど
常に調整する この車を運転するときは
我々はステアリングホイールを捕まっているでしょうに
それで運転する人々は常に調整しながらいるでしょうに
はい これで OK と手を離しますよということはできませんでしょうに
車がブレーキかけてギアを入れてストップするところまで
ステアリングホイールからは手を離してはいけません
だから すべての生まれた時から死ぬまで
これ人生そのものがもう動いている移動中の車のステアリングホイールと同じなんですよ
人生には止まるということ瞬間もないんだから
だから素晴らしい人間っていうのは
その自分の瞬間瞬間生き方っていうのは
この運転中の車のステアリングホイールだと思って
常に何でも調整する能力あること
これ大変なことなんですよ
立派な人間なんですよ
だから悪い例なんですけど
政治競争で生き残る政治家っていうのは誰ですかね？よく調整するんですよ
だから そうやっていろんなこの党に入る次に飛んでいって
他のところに入って またまた元に戻って
また他のところに行ったりとかね
あっちこっちカエルみたいに飛び回ったりするでしょうに
ろくでもない生き方かもしれません
だから政治家として でも
本人が何とかして生き延びるんですね
だから  2年前言ったことと今日言ってることは
もしもう全部記録してるんだから
比べてみると 何やこの人と
ポリシーがないんじゃないかな
言えるぐらいでしょうね
でもそこでその人はもう正しいわけじゃないんだけど
なんでいろんな党をぐるぐる回ったりしてね
野党になったら与党になって
また野党になって いろいろぐるぐる回ったりするかというと
これは我が身はかわいいんだからなんですよ
別に国民のためにやっているわけじゃないんです
だから この主観的であることはもうその通りだから
あの調整は立派な調整じゃなくて
ただだらしないだけ 自分の身を守るためにいろいろもうからくりやったり
調整したりする そういう調整みんなやってますけど
それはもうだらしないだけのことで
私が言うのは もうちゃんと自分で客観的な判断したっても
やっぱりうまくいくように
うまくいくように うまくいくように
人生に事故を起こさないように生きるという
人生のステアリングホイールをちゃんと握って調整していくことなんですね
だから ポイントはこの調整する能力
こういうことをアジャスタビリティ
はい では次のポイント
私たちは何か判断したところで間違っちゃうでしょ
だから怖くて判断できなくなっちゃうんですね
はっきりとイエスとノーと言えないんですね
はっきりと白か黒かで決められない場合もありますね
決められないんじゃなくて
やっぱり決められない
決めたところで あ しまったと
これは違うと 間違ったと
で 間違うことが怖くて
最初からもう決めないで
まあ悠々不断状態になってしまっちゃうんですね
なんで我々の判断結論を間違えますかと
それは怖くて なんで悠々不断になるんでしょうかと
答えは簡単です 心が 頭が腐ってるんです
あまり明確に喋る時間がないんだから
さっさっとはっきりと言いますけどね
このはっきり判断できない人
それからした判断はとんでもない
間違っている場合はもう
もう簡単な答え 心が腐ってるんですよ
心が 醜い 汚い だからできないんですよ
で 心が腐ってるってどういうことかというと
まあ例えば自分が儲かることしか考えない
これ腐ってる考え方でしょうね
これ主観的でしょうね
儲かるということは 他人との関わりの結果として生まれるもので
それを客観的に見ていきてないんですよ
商売で儲かるということは
他人との関わりの結果なんです
だからうまく関わりを持つこと
正しいんであって じゃあ儲かりたい
儲かりたい だからこうします
こうしますだけでいっちゃうと
かなり判断ミスを起こして起こして大変なことになります
それはこのバブル時期というね
日本でなぜ現れたかというと
この心がみんなに腐っていたんだからなんですよ
経済学者は一人もいなかったんだからなんです
経済の世界の論理の基本基礎知ってる人もいなかったんだから
でもまあインテリ中インテリなんですけど
なんでインテリ中のインテリたちが
銀行のもう管理やってる人々が
日銀の偉い人々が 平気でこの国民をね
落とし穴に落としちゃったんですかと
ひどい苦しみに合わせたんですかと
リストラばっかしで それ威張ってるんですよ
リストラして儲かってるんだ
そんな威張ることじゃないんだから
だからそこは心が腐っていたんだ
儲かるんだと だからやれやれと
それだけの考え方で これだけの結果が出てくる
で  崖に落ちてもいいんだけど
崖に崖に落ちたまんまで登ろうとしないんです
登りたいなと思ってるだけで
まだまだ登る方法見つからない
だから問題は作るんだけど
解決法はないんです 心は腐ってるんです
だからそうやってこの自分欲
それから怒り これから嫉妬
憎しみ そういうもので我々は人間と関係を持ってるんですよ
対立している政党 2つがお互いにディスカッションテーブルに来たっても
相手の方は憎しんでるんですよ
潰したいんですよ だからこのディスカッションやったっても
いい結果が出てこないんです
韓国の政治家と北朝鮮の政治家が同じラウンドラウンドテーブルですか
座って じゃあ国際的な会議をやりましょうと
向かない いつでも物別れで終わっちゃうんです
他もうこれ そう言ったら韓国人悪いように感じるかもしれない
そういうことじゃなくて
誰でも同じことで 日本と総連が何かに話し合うたっても
やっぱり答えが出てこない
来年にしますと 再来年にしますと
何千万にもお金かかってね
政治家たちが 話し合ったりして
その政治家の人々はね
1時間の対談というのはすごいお金がかかるでしょうに
もうね そろそろなんとかサミットもやるでしょうに
私はああいうものはね
ものすごいお金がかかる
究極的な贅沢なお祭りだと
何人かが 1時間で 1,000万以上単位でお金使ってお祭りをする
一人の国の政治家が来るということは
もう大変な出動です すごいお金がかかるものだから
1 分単位で計算してみれば
どれぐらいお金がかかるんですかと
で お祭りをやって物別れで解散する
写真だけ ビデオだけで握手をしてニコッと笑って
笑ってばないんですよ
歯を出して終わっちゃうだけ
無駄ですよ あんなものは
じゃあどこかで正しく判断したことがありますか？例えば日本もIMFからいろんなことに
まあヨーロッパに向こうで言われたい放題言われて帰ってくるんですよ
こちらはまあ で 厳しい判断でニュースを見ていると
日本に対しては厳しい判断でしたとかね
だったら自分たちでも自分の言いたいことを言ってみればいいんだけど
まあなんとか言わないかどうかはわかりませんだけど
とにかくこのみんなにいい結果出しましょうという国際会議ではないんですよ
だから この対立している二人が
3 人が あるいは違う意見を持ってる何人かが集めて
国際会議であろうか 個人
個人的な会議であろうか
仏教の会議であるか 国際仏教会議もありますからね
私は一度も行ったことはないし
行かないし 世界仏教協会とかなんとかもありますけどね
で行かない意味はないんだから
お祭りやってお金使って
そんな暇があったら寝るぞと
で行かない 行って祭りをやって喧嘩したらあまり意味がないんだから
祭りをやって終わるんですよ
例えばこの日本やら中国やら大乗仏教の国々と南の仏教の国々は集めて国際会議やりますよ
毎年やってます じゃあ現代人に必要な
そういう大乗僧正対立しない
すごく平和的な平和的な仏教の生き方見つかったんですかね
誰一人も見つかってない
各宗派から行く人々は自分の意見だけ主張して
それでもう言ったら困りますから
じっと我慢して じゃあご飯食べて写真撮って
で みんなと名刺交換して
一回日本で国際会議に偉い人々があっちこっちからね
宗教が来たんだから 私もやっぱり挨拶に行かなくちゃいけないことになっちゃって
挨拶に行ってみたんだけど
日本の偉い人々と各国の偉いお坊さんたちやらね
宗教の人々が来て で 名刺交換しながらね
私もいっぱい名刺を持ってきて
もう来いと あれ飾っておけば
あんたこの人の名刺持ってるんですから
すごいかっこよかったかもしれませんだけど
残念ながらね まあ今思い出しても遅いんですけど
捨てたんです そういうことで
この人間にこの異論がある場合は
なかなか答えが出てこない理由は
この心が腐っている 怒り
憎しみ 欲 自分の意見通してほしいと
それだけでは会議やっても全然意味がない
だから私は言うのは なぜ我々の判断を間違えますかと
なぜ我々は判断しないで
なんとか何とかもう延期するんですね
来年にしますと 北道路では来年でしますという
そのディスカッションは私は日本に来た時からあったんですよ
2000年になってもまだ答えがないんです
政治家はぐるぐるぐるぐる変わりますけど
ソ連でも日本でも話し合いもしますけど
だから答えがなければ
あの時間無駄でしょうに
あのお金は無駄でしょうに
なぜこう答えが出てこないかというと
やっぱり自己主張 それは問題なんです
だから頭が人類の頭が心が腐りすぎなんですよ
貪瞋痴で 怒りで 憎しみで
欲で だからものを見えるはずがないんです
怒りも欲も憎しみもすべて主観的だと私は最初から言ったんだから
主観というのは本当はもういい加減なもので
ちょっとしたことで変わりますから
ちょっとしたことでそれ変わりますでしょうに
だから何の意味もないんです
それにしがみついて頭が悪くなるだけ
だから正しく答えを出すために
たった一つの方法がありますよ
まああのまあ心は心の汚れを落とすということは結構時間かかりますから
もう最初からもうね もう生命に対して平等な気持ちで
人は負けてはよくないんだと
自分の態度で 自分の判断で
自分の決めたことで 誰かに迷惑をかけたら
誰か負けてしまったら
誰かが不幸になったら
誰かが損したら それは自分としては立派じゃないんだと
たとえ会社の商談相談であろうとも
両側も得しなくちゃいけないんだと
子供と相談に乗っても
やっぱり両側はまあよかったよかったと
両方得するようにしなくちゃいけないんだと
ですから まあ得するようにしましょうと思ったらうまくいかないんだから
もうお釈迦様が言うのは
他人に対して限りない慈しみを持ちなさいよと
相手に迷惑をかけてはいけない
相手に損させてはいけない
相手を苦しませてはいけない
相手も喜ぶような方向へ導かなくちゃいけないんだと
そういう気持ちを持って行動すると
いとも簡単に答えが出てくる
そういうことで 我々の心がこの憎しみではなくて
怒りではなくて 嫉妬ではなくて
欲ではなくて 慈しみで起動させちゃうと
いつでも正しい答えが出てくる
例えば あの森の中から熊が出てくるんだと
行った途端 出す判断は
じゃあ行って殺そうと
危ないと それは正しい答えじゃないんです
熊が出るんだ じゃあ行って殺そう
簡単単純で これ自分たちだけの答えでしょうに
すると熊には何の権利もないんです
熊が何か悪いことしたんですかね？何も悪いことしてないのに
で 殺そうと だから人間同士でそうでしょ
平気で じゃあ殺そうと
言って殺してるでしょうに
個人で個人を殺しちゃったら殺人ですけど
集団で集団殺す 殺人でもなんでもないでしょうに
立派な行為だと思ってるでしょうに
戦争とか何とか解放運動とか何とか名前をつけちゃって大量に殺す
その場合は殺人罪でもなんでもないヒーローなんですね
だからそういうのは人間の正しい生き方ではないし
だから熊が入ってきたら
じゃあ熊を殺そうということではないんですよ
答えは だからまあ 我々も安心して
熊にも自由に生きていられるように状況を作るということなんですけど
そう考えちゃうとちょっとややこしくなるんだから
仏教で言うのはそうじゃなくて
逆に熊のことを考えなさいと
熊に対して慈しみを持ちなさいと
この熊さんがまあ気持ちよく自分の世界で生活できるようにどうすればいいんでしょうかと
そうすると熊に安心して生活できるような状況にしてあげれば
熊はもう面倒くさいんだから
人家に入ろうとはしないんです
熊も好きで来るわけじゃないんだから
動物は人間のことをものすごく怖がって嫌いんですよ
だから森の中で生活できれば落ち着いて生活しますよ
人に他人に迷惑をかけない動物は
餌を食べたらグーグーと寝るんだから
それ以上何もしませんだからね
ですから 他人に対して慈しみだけ持てば
大体答えがすぐ出てくるんです
そこで言いたいのは 答えっていうのは私が持っているわけじゃないんですよ
これは 1番目のポイントにまた戻りますけど
みんな話し合いはするんだけど
最初から答えを持っている
あれ とんでもない話なんです
私が言いたいポイントはそうじゃなくて
答えを持ってないんだと
持っているのは問題だけですよと
頭の中にある固定概念で感情で作った答えは忘れるんです
あれは答えじゃないんだと
私の主観だけだと だから答えは持ってません
それで対立している問題が出てきたんだと
その時は じゃあ相手に対して慈しみを持って
じゃあ考えましょうということ
考えてみると そこに答えが現れてくるんです
だから正しい答えっていうのは
決して前もって作っている答えではありません
その場で新しく誕生するんです
それはよく覚えていただきたいんです
どんな問題でも 答えというのはテキストにあるわけじゃないんです
聖典 経典にあるわけじゃないんです
自分の経験の中にあるわけではないんです
どんな問題も新しい問題ですから
そこで他人に対して慈しみでものをことを考えちゃうと
そこに新しく 誕生するってんですよ
答えが それを覚えておけばね
うまくいけると思います
答えっていうのは新しく誕生するものだよと
ニフボーン そこで相手に親切に我々は行動したりする
その場合は物事を考えなくてはいけないんですね
例えば国際問題にしたっても
中国と日本の間の問題にしたっても
韓国と日本の間の問題もいろいろ
アメリカと日本の問題にしたっていろいろ問題あります
皆様にもいろいろ個人的にいろんな問題があります
そういう問題ある場合は
母親と子供の間に問題が起きたりする
夫婦の間で問題が起きたりする
いつでも相手がいるんですよ
で そこで相手に対して親切に
相手に対して慈しみを持って
相手の幸せを思って考えたりする
それで答えが誕生する
そういうふうに考えるために必要なのは
仏教で大変有名な言葉なんですけど
この言葉なんですね ヨーニソーマネシカーラ
経典どこを読んでみたっても
お釈迦様はなぜ人が間違いますか？なぜ悪い行動をしますかと
なぜいけない考え方を作っちゃうんですかと
なぜ世の中で戦争やらトラブルやらあるんですかと
なぜ人間が幸せになりたい
幸せになりたいと思って苦しみしか作らないんですかと
すべてこのヨーニソーマネシカーラがないんだからと
これ否定形でアヨーニソーマネシカーラと言うんです
その場合は だから これからお釈迦様の経典なんか読んでみてください
どんな問題 問題についてお釈迦様が言うのは
これはアヨーニソーマネシカーラですよ
だから問題なくすためにはヨーニソーマネシカーラというものが必要なんですね
で これなかなか日本訳しにくい言葉なんですよ
日本訳もしにくいし 英訳もしにくいし
何でしょうかと ということは人類に答えないんだからなんですよ
いまだに一つも問題解決したことないでしょ
だから我々の頭の中でヨーニソーマネシカーラっていうのは 1個あったことはないんです
一度も だから日本語にしたっても
英語にしたっても ドイツ語にしたっても
単語さえないんです それはお釈迦様がお話しした言葉で
本当は訳しにくいんです
じゃあ意味は言いますけど
これは 物事を客観的に見なさいという意味なんです
でも ヨニソマニセカーラ
客観的と翻訳したら翻訳間違っちゃうんですね
だから翻訳 パーリ聖典翻訳するときは決して客観的とは翻訳しません
なぜならば 仏教は客観主義だということは
どんな仏教学者もわかってないんだから
もう一つの宗教だと勘違いしているんだから
お釈迦様は偉い科学者でしたとわかってないんですから
だから私は言葉を調べて調べたところで
はめる言葉っていうのは
本当は客観的ということなんです
で その中で見方も入ってるんです
どのように物事を見るんですかと
ヨニソマニセカーラ マニセカーラっていうのは考えること
このマニセカーラっていうのは考えるという意味なんです
思考 この考える場合は
ヨニソ あるがままに 順番にという
このあるがままにという
あ こういうことで こういう問題が起きた
こういうこういう原因で
こういう問題が起きた
このように見ているんだから
こういうことが起きたと
すごく客観的に観察することがヨニソなんですよ
例えば 子供が学校に行きたくないから
そんなこと言ったら困りますよとすぐ反応出すでしょうね
それは客観的じゃなくて主観的
自分の気持ち 自分の心配なんです
で それで喧嘩になっちゃうんですね
だから子供が学校に行きたくないと思ったら
あ 学校に行きたくないという問題がありますと
なぜそういう問題が起きたかと
それで客観的に分析してみればいいんです
別にとにかく学校に行かせてやるぞとかね
そうやって自分の意見を出すんじゃないんですよ
客観的に分析してみると
すぐ新しく答えが生まれてくるんです
だから この相手に対して親切にヨニソマニセカーラでやらなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば今出した例ですから
子供が学校に行きたくないと言ったら
いっぱい質問すれば あるいはまあ
いつから学校に行きたくなったんですかと
今日初めてですかと 昨日もそういう気持ちでしたかと
そうすると時間の経過わかるでしょ
一番最初に学校嫌だなと思ったのはいつでしたかと
その時どういうことでしたかと
そうやって時間の経過と流れを理解してみる
それ同時にその原因とこちらの対応
子供の対応 それはちゃんと把握できる
で 最初に子供にも気持ちありますから
子供主観的だからね あなたは正直なところ
学校に行きたいんですか？行きたくないんですか？と
それもありますから 本当は行きたいんだけど
行きたくないという気持ちもあるし
いえ 人が何言おうと 学校は家に戻ろうと
私は行きたく参加したくないという場合
また違いますからね で
それ一つ それからあなたは勉強は嫌いですか？ないですかと
そういうこともありまして
将来についてどう考えているんですか？ないんですかと
どのように考えているんですか？と
自分の人生設計はどういうふうに立てるつもりですかと
そうやってたくさん質問さえすれば
問題がちゃんと見えてくる
もしかすると答えは この子は勉強は好きかもしれません
でも 学校の環境 雰囲気は自分に合わないかもしれません
逆に学校に行かせたら悪い結果になるかもしれません
だったら だったら あなたにとって特別な勉強する方法を探しましょうと
学校はいらんと あんたそういう気持ちでそんなに勉強もできて
勉強も好きでしょうしね
こういうこういう勉強したいでしょうし
だったらじゃあそういうふうにやりましょうという答えが出てくるでしょうね
最初からなんとかして子供を学校に行かせてもらって
それで終わりと という気持ちで答えが出てこないんです
だから問題が起きたら
答えが新生する 新しく生まれてくるんですよ
それは相手もこちらも予想したものじゃないんです
それに必要なのは このヨニソマニセカーラということ
ヨニソマニセカーラはだから日本訳もない言葉なんですけど
すごく客観的にわかりやすく言えば
この物事の順番 なぜこの問題になったかと
いきなり突然問題というのは現れません
ゆっくりと現れるんですよ
たとえ予知できない地震にしたっても
いきなり突然地震が起こるわけじゃないんです
我々は知らないだけで
地下にあるあのいろいろ活動があって
その活動をゆっくりゆっくりゆっくりゆっくり積み重ねて
地震という結果になるだけ
決してある日突然地震が起きたということはありません
何年もゆっくりと地下で行動を起こして起きて起きて
やがて地震ということですからね
だからどんな問題でもゆっくりと順番で成り立たれるものだから
その順番を見てみる 原因関係と見てみて
大きくなった問題はまた小さくして小さくして持っていくためにはどういう順番でよろしいかということだけなんですよ
だから そんな簡単にイエスかノーかとかには出てこないでしょうね
それはヨニソ マニシカーラということなんです
もう一つ言葉を覚えておきましょう
これは反対の言葉で お釈迦様はこんなことだったら地獄に落ちますよまで脅している言葉なんですよ
ディッティガーラ で こんなことをやったら
もうもうもうどうにもならないんだと
あまりにも激しくディッティガーラになったら
もう地獄に落ちるんだよと
そこまで脅す脅しするところまで大変な言葉なんです
やってはいけないこと
ヨニソ マニシカーラというのは
我々にあってほしいこと
ディッティガーラというのは
自分の意見をものすごく意見に囚われてしがみついていくことなんです
自分の考え方に いわゆる主観ですよ
ヨニソ マニシカーラは客観
だから自分の意見に 自分の主観に
これこそ正しいとものすごくしがみついていること
ディッティガーラと言うんです
自分の意見にしがみついていたら
もう救いの道がないんだと
どうにもならないんだと
真理は一向にわかるくはないんだと
それはもう徹底的に避けた方がいいんです
自分には意見あるかもしれませんだけど
それはまあとりあえずということで
とりあえず私はこういう意見ですけどということなんです
ディッティガーラしがみついているわけじゃないんです
まあ条件変わったら変わりますよと
あなたは全くもうすごい良い意見を出すならば
私の意見を変えますよと
まあこれは例で考えれば
例えば夏休みはもう 北海道に行くことを決めたところで
相手は北海道じゃなくてもっと安くて台湾旅行できますよと
もっと面白いんですよ
北海道どうせ日本だから
そしたら ああ そうですか
だったらじゃあ台湾に行こうということなんです
いい 私が決めたんだから
人が何と言おうとも お金いくらかかろうとも
北海道に行くんだというのはディッティガー派なんです
まあとりあえずこういう風に考えているんだけど
もっとすごいいい計画あったら
じゃあそちらに変更しますというのはディッティガー派じゃないんです
だから 人生においてよく気をつけてください
すべての人間がディッティガー派なんです
自分の意見は変えたくない
だからヨニソマニスカラはなし
単語さえない 英訳しているテキストを見てみたんだけど
適切な英訳じゃないんです
なんとか訳するだけで
その訳は訳だから 私が言う意味はどこにもないんです
私は実際に実践の世界で
お釈迦様はどのようにこの言葉を使っていたかということは
現代の言葉で言うだけだからね
そういうのはどんなテキストでもないんです
あ もう時間は終わりましたけど
そこでこの中道って何なのかということで
あと分以内でなんとか終わります
え？までじゃないの え？長すぎ
それだったら じゃあそういうことだったら
もうさっさと終わりまで言います
そこで皆様よく聞いている言葉っていうのは
マッジマパティカータ
中道ということなんですね
仏教は中道であるということは
これは誰でも知っています
誰でも知っていますからね
仏教は中道ですから でも誰も仏教の人々も知らないのは中道は何ですか？と
それは何と まあ試しに遊びにいろんな宗教家に聞いてみてください
仏教の中で仏教のもういろんな宗教に分かれているんだから
まず仏教というのは中道ですかということをご存知で
まあその通りですよと威張って言うかもしれません
これ中道って何なのかと
聞いたら色々意見が出ると思います
結局は仏教は中道でありということは知ってますけど
この中道は何なのかというとわからないんです
それだったら何の役にも立たんでしょうに
だから中道って何なのかということをはっきり理解していない
で みんな思うのは この中道だから
この真ん中の道やと 同時にいい加減な道じゃないんですかね
真ん中の道です 両極端的な意見 2つがありまして
じゃあ半分半分で じゃあここら辺で真ん中にしましょうと
そうするといい加減な道なんですね
そこで龍樹かな この真ん中の道はもうもう悪いと
という数学的に説明するんですよ
例えば 何か意見があるね
それはもう間違っているんだと
極端だから それに正反対の意見がある
それも極端だから間違っていると
じゃあ真ん中にしましょうと
真ん中っていうのは 一つの完璧な悪い意見の半分でしょ
もう一つの完璧に悪い意見の半分でしょ
じゃあ完璧に悪い半分合体したらどうですかね
半分足す半分は 1 でしょうに
もう一つ感的に悪い意見が生まれてくるだけなんです
例えば左は間違ってるんだと
で 極端的な右も間違ってるんだと
真ん中ですよ そういう意味じゃないんです
そうすると真ん中も間違ってますよ
だから中道っていうのは決して曖昧という意味ではないんです
だから私は日本訳する場合は超越道にしましょうと
中道ではなくて 人間の道とは違うんだと
人間には何も判断 決断できない
問題を作るだけのかたまりですからね
こういう人間の道ではないんだと
これは超越道やと で 仏教で中道というのは
いつでも正しい判断できるような生き方なんです
間違い 間違い犯さないような生き方なんですよ
だから今日は判断のテーマだから
だから判断というのはどうせ間違っちゃうでしょうに
普通に判断しちゃったら意見 2つあると
もうとにかく相手の意見を潰そうということでやるでしょうね
そうすると強引な人が勝ちますけど
それは正しいわけじゃないんです
例えば 世の中でアメリカの意見通じているでしょうに
だから正しいということはないんですよ
向こうはもう強引だから
力強いんだから 力で抑えちゃうだけ
それでみんなはいはい
わかりましたと 他の国々は行動する
そんな強引に自分の意見を押しつけても
それは正しいわけでもないんです
例えば 中国についてアメリカが人権問題
人権問題とか偉く喋る
それで世界中みんな やっぱり中国はもう本当に人権問題を真面目に考えなくちゃいけないんだと
と勘違いもする じゃあアメリカはちゃんと人権問題
人権 権利を守ってますかね
自分の国の中で 自分たちもやりたい放題でしょうに
大差さがないと思いますけどね
中国とは でも自分たちの生き方正しいんだからやりなさいと
中国人にとっては大きなお世話なんです
我々には我々の生き方あるんだと
だから商売の話だったらしましょうと
政治の話だったらもうもうごめんと
で 帰るんです  そういうふうに問題が起きたら
そういうふうなことが出てきたりする
ですから この人間というのは
二人がいて 問題が作っちゃうと
力強い人が 一番頭の悪い人が自分の意見を通ってもらう
自分の意見はいろいろ批判されると腹が
怒って感情的になって
暴力まで振るったりして
とにかく自分の意見を通してもらおうと
それでも通らない場合
私は出て行くぞと もうあんた方とは何の関係もないんだと
それも暴力なんですね
それはとにかく自分の意見を通って欲しがっちゃう
それいる 正しい答えではありません
ただ 中道というのはいくらか手を抜いて
いくらか手を緩めてということですかね
それも正しくないんですよ
だから前に説明したように
相手に対して慈しみを持って
それから世にそうマヌスからで客観的に考えたら
自分持っていた答えでもなく
相手が持っていた答えでもなく
新しく誕生する二人にも賛成できる答えがあるんですね
それが中道なんです 単語がなかったんだから
お釈迦様も中道という言葉を使ったんですけど
なぜかというと 超越という言葉はあるんですよ
お釈迦様はそれは違う場所で使っているんです
ですから お釈迦様はこの人間の実践方法に
あの中という言葉はマッジマという見るという言葉を使ったんですね
だからそこははっきり理解しないで
これは真ん中の道だと思ったら
それはえらい誤解になっちゃうんです
真ん中の道ではありません
これは超越の道なんですね
ですから この超越の道を発見した人
身に染みた人が超越した人間だというんですよ
その教えに超越した教えたというんですよ
だから違うところで超越
超越という言葉を使っているんです
うっかりマヌッサという言葉
だからうっかりっていうのはもう上ということで
乗り越えているということ
マヌッサ 人間の生き方はもう乗り越えていると
だから他のところで使っているんだから
この中道には使ってないんです
で 理由がありますよ 中道を実践する人が普通の人間だから
実践した結果で人間 普通の人間は乗り越えられますから
だから結果に超越という言葉を使っているんです
道に使ってないんです
まあそこはややこしいんだから
そこら辺をまあ別に忘れたってもいいんですけど
あの そこで二人が話し合っている場合は
私にも私の意見があって
相手にも相手の意見があるんだけど
それはもう主観ですからね
まあとりあえずこういう意見だよと
それで話し合っちゃうと
ああ 二人にも賛成できる考え方はこういう考え方ではないかと
新しい考え方が出てきます
その新しい考え方が中道の判断なんですね
だから自分負けたわけでもないし
勝ったわけでもないし
でも損していないんです
答えが自分には大変いい答えなんです
相手も勝ったわけでもないし
負けたわけでもないし
でも出した結論は相手にとってもすごくそれ植えない結論なんです
だったら万々歳でしょう
いろんな国際問題もね
そういう立場で見るんだったら解決方法出ますよ
例えば台湾という島がありますね
それは中国のものやと
もう一向に頑固って中国は決まってるんです
で 今までは西洋の国々は中国っていうのは台湾ですよと
中国という国はないんだと
言って中国大陸はないようにしていたんですね
でも でも地図にありますからね
政治になくても 国連のあの 5つの国が権力を持ってるでしょ
そこでも台湾が入ってたんだから
で それで世界平和だと
あるわけないでしょ ま
とにかく後で まあ一応中国になってなってましたけど
で まあ一旦中国を認めるようになってきて
それで中国は台湾は私たちの土地ですと
台湾国は私たちのものやと言わないんです
台湾という島 その土地
中国のものですと それすごい頑固なんですね
でも台湾人がそうなりたいかと
違う意見でしょう それで怖い問題が出てくる
そこでもし台湾は中国の一部になったらどうなるかと
台湾の人々に対してどうなるんでしょうかと
経済活動どうなるんですかと
生き方はどうなるんですかと
あの政治システムが嫌だからこちらでいるんだから
あれは台湾人が損する
すべて自由を失ってしまっちゃう
経済成長もなくなってしまっちゃう
豊かさもなくなってしまっちゃう
じゃあどうすればいいんですかと
そこで中国の主張でもなく
台湾の主張でもなく 何かあるはずなんです
中国もこれだったらいいんじゃないかと
台湾もまあこれだったらいいんじゃないかと
という答えがあるんですよ
ちょっと考えれば だからそういうふうに
このいろんな問題を解決できるんです
どんな国々の問題でも
で そこは国際的な問題だけではなくて
民主問題でも何でも 人間の問題でも
親子の問題でも そうやって考えちゃうと中道的な答えが出てきます
この中道的な答えっていうのは
Aさんの意見通ったわけでもなく
Bさんの意見通ったわけでもなく
Aさんにも Bさんにも一番いい答えが出すことなんです
時々 このイスラエルの問題にしたっても
まだまだ解決してないんだけど
まあ一応解決しなくちゃいけないんだと
なんとかしましょうというところまで行ったのは
そういう第三者が入って
ノーノーノルウェーなんですけどね
入って話をしたんだからなんです
ノルウェーの国が別にもうイスラエル人万歳ということでもないし
パレスチナ人万歳ということでもなくて
お互いにどちらの方がいいんですかと
両側のことを心配して
これで大変やと あんた方殺し合いばっかしやっていてね
だから二人にもいい方は何でしょうかと考えましょうと言ったところで
両側もじゃあ話しましょうと
だから三人で話し合って
いくらかの決まりになったんですね
それで後からアメリカが自分がやったんだという
それは大嘘で ただ入り込んだだけなんですけど
で サインする時はアメリカの大統領がいてサインしたんだけど
本当は後ろに隠れているところでノルウェーの代表者もいたんですね
したのはその人なんですけど
だから立派な人なんです
なぜならというと そのために喧嘩しなかったんですよ
あ どうぞどうぞ 威張りたければどうぞ
その方がもっとうまくいくんだと
アメリカを立ててあげたら
どうせあの国は小さいしね
力もないし 立派だと思いますね
だからそこで何かどちらにでも認められる答えが出てくる
それなんでいい パレスチナ人とユダ人の問題
なんであの一応契約書いたのに
なんでうまくいかないかというと
いまだに自分たちだけ得することを考えているんですね
取った土地をあげたくないんだと
で パレスチナ人も暴力振るおう
暴力振るうとか だからうまくいかないのは
そのまだまだ中道の考え方になってないんだからなんです
だから得するんだったら両方を得せなくちゃいけないと
という気持ちにならないと
それにはわがままを捨てなきゃ決して成り立たないんだということに
軸足執着を捨てないと成り立たないとわからないとね
そういうことだから この正しい結論を出す道
仏教では中道と言うんです
マッジマーパティパダーというんです
それは真ん中の道ではなくて
超越した道なんです それで次のポイントに行きます
じゃあそれから中道って何なのかと
これは曖昧なものかと
いい加減なものかという問題なんですけど
お釈迦様はこの曖昧ないい加減なことを中道だとは言ってないんです
これははっきりした生き方だと
これしかない生き方だと
中道っていうのはもう選択ない
そういう生き方だで説明しているんです
ですから 中道って何なのかというと
お釈迦様が最初に言うのは正見
パーリ語でサンマーディッキと言うんですね
次に正思惟かな どなたか書いてください
今 今もうそれだけでいいんです
うん うん  うん また後で来て下さい
で 最初に正見 この正見というのは自分の主観
自分の意見 それ捨てなさいということ
客観的に見なさいということ
まず考え方から始まらないと
私の意見だからといってね
私はこれを信じているんだから
そういう風に言っちゃうと
頭が良くなるわけじゃないんです
ですから この超越度を正しい判断したければ
まず自分の頭はしっかりしなくちゃいけない
それで問題は じゃあ正見って何なのかと
これわからないでしょうに
それでお釈迦様は答え出してる
正見というのは 物事は一時的でありますよ
固定してないんです なんでも
今日は優しい子は明日も優しいというわけじゃないんです
固定しないんですよ 今日優しい子は明日は乱暴になるかもしれませんしね
今日は100点取ったんだけど
次のテストで40点かもしれません
物事一つも固定してないんです
何一つも それはよく理解しましょう
だから人間問題を起こしちゃうのは
自分が考えたことでずっと一生やりたがるんでしょうに
そううまくいかないんですよ
たとえ国に憲法を作ったっても
それで100年頑張りましょう
とはありえない話なんですよ
憲法を作るのは その時の条件ともうちょっとまあ将来のことも考えて
頑張っては作りますけどね
でも世の中の条件やら国の条件やらいろいろ変わりますからね
たとえ憲法であろうとも
改正しなくちゃいけないことにはなるんですよ
法律だからといって固定していますか？法律は固定してないんですよ
その日その日で新しい法律が出てくるんだから
古い法律を変えたり変えたりするんだから
例えば 18歳までは子供ですよと
犯罪には問いませんよと言われたとこはすごいうまいことに使っちゃって
12歳で人を殺す  17歳 11ヶ月で人を殺すとかね
18歳になってないんだから
それでもうただでご飯食べて
もう楽々に社会に戻ると
やりたい放題です その場合は
ですから そういうことをやってくると
やっぱり法律を変えなくてはいけないんですね
アメリカのどっかの地方で殺人だったら
たとえ子供であろうとも
他の問題の場合は子供は子供扱いするんだけど
殺人だったら普通に裁判を起こすと
まさかもう子供までもうそんなことやり始めたんだから
ですから あの  18歳未満は子供だよという法律は固定しているわけじゃないんですよ
のを変えなくてはいけないことにもなります
もうその条件に応じて
ですから 世の中のことは何でも変えて変えて変化していく
なんでそれ理解しないかと
自分が結婚した相手が自分に対する愛情っていうのは
結婚したその日であったような感じで一生あると思ったら
それは大違いんですよ
愛情であろうか それをその日で
その日でお互いの関係によって成り立つものなんですよ
固定して安定してないんです
それでみんな失敗するでしょうに
奥さんのほうが旦那さんの方が自分のことを大変愛しているんだと
なるこれは変わらないだろうと勘違いしたところで
大変なひどい目に遭っちゃう
で 男の人も自分の奥さんだからね
自分のことしか考えてないと思ったところで
とんでもない結果になってしまっちゃう
で 結婚したんだからといって
男女の間に愛情はもう決めましたと
神様が決めたんだからと
そんな嘘は世の中に成り立ちません
だから結婚する相手は神が決めているんだというふうに
西洋的な思想があるでしょ
本当にそうだったら 結婚したら離婚しないはずなんですよ
離婚の数が一番多いのは
この神様を信じてる世界でしょうに
でも結婚は日本人も求めて教会でやるんですね
ああいう間違っている考え方に基づいてやるもんですよ
神様のまで司会をしてとかね
まあ嘘の司会はもう邪見に基づいた嘘の司会だからね
もう 1ヶ月間  2ヶ月間でもうダメになっちゃう
だから仏教でいうのはすべて変化するんだと
だから夫婦は 仲良くしたければ
死ぬ日までお互いに心配し合ったり
労わり合ったりしなきゃあかんですよ
10年間お互いに労わり合ってきたっても
11年目から無視するようになっちゃったら別れてしまいますよ
お互いに口をきかなくなっちゃうんです
ですから この正見というのは
それを理解すること 何一つも固定していないんだと
例えば 私は今ベラベラ喋ってるんだからといって
この能力はずっとあると思いますが
それはないと思います
もしもうおじさんになったことも私にも起きちゃったら終わりだから
わからないんですよ ボケてしまったら
それで終わりでしょうし
だからもう何でも固定していない
だから瞬間瞬間努力しなくちゃいけない
で 大学に入って 例えばみんなやっていることだからね
まあ受験までは真面目に勉強する
あ やったんだからということで
大学に入ったから それっきり死ぬまで勉強しない
だから教育レベルは高いんだけど
頭のいい人はほとんどなしという
状態になっているでしょうに
だからそういうことは良くないんですよ
頭が良くなって欲しければ
毎日頑張らないと ゴールポイントはないんですよ
死ぬときまでよ ですから
まあ正見というのはどんなものもコンディショナル条件によって成り立つもので
固定していない 変化していく
変わる 明日次にどうなるかわからない
そういうことや それから何やっても別に意味があるわけじゃないんだと
例えば何か決めるでしょ
正しい決め方じゃないでしょ
例えば ある人が音楽家になりたいと決める
その決断は正しいんですかね
正しくないんですよ ただ
その時の条件によってそう決めただけ
ある人が建築家になろうとする
ある人が何かになろうと思ったりする
若い時は それは正しい判断ではありません
間違っている判断でもありません
まあとりあえずその条件でそう決めただけのことで
そこで音楽家になろうと思ったんだけど
研究もしたんだけど 練習もしたんだけど
まあ大変な苦労やと 食べていられ
食べ食べられませんと
あ これは収入にならない
プロにならないと思っちゃう時は
もしかするともう歳も取っていて
他の仕事を探すともうあれ
収入 それでもしたって収入がないと
そういうことにもなりかねませんし
あるいは結局虚しいんじゃないかなと
そんなことをしたっても
大したことじゃないとも感じるでしょ
そう感じることは正見なんです
いわゆる我々は決断して何をしたっても
最終的な結果っていうのはろくな結果じゃないんです
たとえ音楽家になっても
だから何でしょうかと
たとえすごい医者になったってもね
それ人生成功したんでね
大したことないんですよ
ただ患者さんいじめてるだけで
弁護士になろうと思って弁護士になったとする
ただ嘘をついて人のお金を奪ってるだけで
結局は虚しいんですよ
じゃあ教師になってやるぞと思って教師になったっても
立派な教師になれるわけじゃないし
死ぬ 死ぬまでか退職するまで同じ年の子供たちと一緒に生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分には何の成長もなくなっちゃうんですよ
例えば小学生の先生だったら
退職するまで小学生相手でしょうに
えらいつまらなくなると思いますよ
毎年毎年同じこと 同じ問題
だから同じ年で同じ問題作るんだから
同じ教科書 すごいつまらないと思います
だからそこは理解してしなさいよと
この世の中で完璧なぴったしという判断
生き方はないんだと まあとりあえず何か選んでやるんだと
まあそれも結局は最後には虚しくなるんだと
それを理解することは正見なんです
物事は固定していない
変化していく 何か決めたっても
大したことではありませんと
決めたことは大胆に このもう時代の革命みたいなそうなりませんと
例えばアインシュタインさんがね
いろいろものを考えたりしたんだけど
今から考えて まあまあどうったことないと
ということになるでしょうに
そういうことは正見 だから曖昧ではありません
それを理解してくださいと
だから経典を読んでみてください
苦であること 渇愛 あれ
空・渋・滅・道 それを理解することは正見だよと
と言っているのはそういうわけなんです
だから正見では私は正しい意見持ちましょうと
そういうのは成り立たない
正見持って教育者になりますと
正見でもって子供育てますよと
そんな正見というのはあるわけじゃないんです
それは正見でもない 単なる主観で
正見というのは 物事は固定していない
変化していくんだ 何か決めたっても
すぐ変わってしまっちゃうんだ
決めたものはしがみついてやったっても
最終的には虚しいんだと
そんなどうったことはないんだと
すべてはドッカであると
という理解があれば もう頭は綺麗なんですよ
どんな判断もできる その人には
次に正思惟 それから人間というのはいろんなことを考えるでしょ
だから考えては間違う
考えては間違う 考える時はいつでも主観で考える
客観で考えることはなかなかできません
皆様方 大体客観に考えるのは
この数学の問題解決するとき
それから将棋とか ゲームをやっている時はまあ主観的じゃないんです
主観的だったら将棋負けますからね
その時は将棋板の上にある駒の配列で考えるんです
これはこれにあって これはこれにあって
向こうはこういう風にあるんだから
じゃあこうしますと そういうのは客観的な考え方なんです
普通に考えてるとすべて主観的なんです
今日は何食べようかと思ったら
それは結論ははっきりと主観的なんです
将棋の板の上で考えたような感じで考えたことじゃないんですよ
だから上手な将棋のプロだったら
一つの駒を動かしちゃうとそれしか選択ないんですよ
決まりはこれですと また回ステップ考えているかもしれませんだけど
1番目はこれ そうすると向こうはこうするしか方法ない
で  2番目はこの駒を動かすと
それは客観的な考え方
で 夜何食べようかなと思う時は客観的じゃないんです
なぜならば それしかないということじゃないでしょ
夜は天ぷらにしましょうと
その人にはそれしか食べ物ないんですかね
天ぷら食べなかったら死ぬんですかね
いえ ラーメン食べても同じことなんです
ですから その場合は主観的なんです
そういうことは考える世界の問題なんです
だからお釈迦様はね この考え方は気をつけてほしいんですよ
気をつけてと言っても
正しく考えなさいと言ったっても
どう考えればいいんですかね
じゃあ正しく考えるんだと
できるんですかね できないんですよ
正思は できないんだから
またお釈迦様の知恵が出てくるんですよ
こういうふうにしたらどうですかと
怒りに怒りを持って考えてはいけませんと
相手のことを憎んで 憎しみに基づいて
憎しみの感情で考えるなよと
怒りの感情で考えるなよと
何か考えるとか あ 嫌だな
あの人のことという感じになってきたら
まあじゃあだからこうしましょうと
その判断は良くないんです
相手のことを怒って考えたんだから
それから欲に基づいて
考えてはいけません と欲に心が汚れていたら
その考え方をやめるんです
で  3つあります  3番目はこの他人をね
潰したい 暴力振りたい
壊したいという この破壊的な気持ち
どうすれば我々は戦争を勝ちますか？とかね
そういう破壊的なことは考えないこと
例えば悪い人がいて その人を殴りたくなる
で 殴って あるいは殺したくなる
で それいきなり殺しちゃったら自分が捕まりますから
いろいろ考える 計画立てる
計画立てる 立てて 他の人と仲良くしてあげて
また紹介してあげたりして
その人にまあ殺されるようにするとか
それで自分がセーフだと
そういうことで世の中でいっぱい犯罪は起こします
だから この相手に対して暴力
害を与えるような気持ちが生まれたら
まるっきりそういうことを考えないこと
だからやめること 3つしかないんですよ
それだけやめて自由に考えればいいんです
欲に欲ばっかしで心が汚れていて汚染したら
もうそういうことを考えないようにする
怒り 苛立ち 暗闇が出てきたら
その思考はストップする
例えば 私は何をやってもダメだなとかね
うまくいかないんだとかね
そういう暗いでしょうね
その怒りなんですね まあいいや
そんな考え方は暗いんだからと
すぐそこをやめる やめちゃってテレビで見た方がいいんです
テレビで見ると あの考え方は出てこないんだと
あるいは音楽でも聞いた方がいいんです
あるいは何か本でも読んだ方がいいんです
そうやって この正思というのはいきなり育てることはできません
できませんだから やってはいけない思考だけを 3つ覚えておいて
それを避ける そうすると
すごい精神的に 心理学的にも完璧な人間が成り立つんですよ
この心理学的にはみんないろいろ問題を起してるでしょ
消えちゃうんです それは考え方がまずいんだからなんです
そういうことで まず考え方から問題解決するんです
それから我々の生き方
生き方の場合は どんな生き方が正しいかとか
これまたわからないんですよ
子供を叱った方がいいんですか？親切にした方がいいんですか？甘えてあげた方がいいんですか？わからないんですよ
ずっと甘えてあげたらまた悪くなっちゃうし
厳しくしちゃうとまた悪くなっちゃうし
叱ることばっかりやってやっちゃうとまたダメになっちゃうし
褒めることをしちゃったら
また子供の能力なくなってしまっちゃうし
どうすればいいかわからないんですよ
仕事の場合でも同じこと
張り切り 張り切って仕事をしても
あまりうまくいかない時もあるし
あまり自分が張り切りすぎて他の人とかみ合わない時もあるし
じゃあ中途半端やったらそれまたダメでしょうし
だからほどほどといったほどほどってどれぐらいかわからないし
どうでしょうかね 例えば自分の奥さんに対してよく褒めてあげればいいんだなと
そうすると向こうは機嫌が良くなって
まあ家庭を守るだろうと思って
まあよく褒めると向こうは馬鹿にしちゃうんですね
で 褒めないで無視しちゃうとまたもう腹が立ってくるんですね
向こうは だから人間にとってはどうすればいいかっていうことはもうわからないもんだっすよ
だからお釈迦様がだったら簡単な方法で決めましょうと
で  3つ サンマーワーチャーサンマーカンマンとサンマーアージーワという 3つを教えるんですね
それだけ頑張って守ってくださいと
サンマーワーチャー正語
正しい言葉喋ってくださいと
じゃあ正しい言葉喋ってくださいったって
何が正しい言葉ですかね
わかりますかね 正しい言葉って何でしょうかと
例えば自分が言ったことは
他の事実と比べてみればそうでないかもしれませんし
科学の世界ではね 昔何か発見して
これこそ真理だと一生懸命教えてってしたんだけど
新しいものを発見して
あれ あれ間違いましたと
そうすると 前の先生たちは何を教えたんですかね
だから何が正しいかといえば
明日 今日言ったことは明日で変わりますから
だから単なる正しい言葉でいたってわからないんです
だからお釈迦様はこれだけ守ってくださいと
まず嘘を言うなよと だから今事実だと認めているものを言えばいいんです
明日 それは事実でなくてもしょうがないんですよ
今日はこれは事実だよということを喋ればいいんです
だから事実なのに それをねじ曲がって嘘を言う
それはやめなさい それから人にね
きつい言葉言ったり 叱ったり
人の気持ちが悪くなる言葉
それやめましょうと 暴力的な言葉
人の気持ちがすごく嫌な気持ちになる
叱りの言葉とか あれはやめた方がいいと
何の結果にもならない
ただ人間関係悪くなるだけ
それから噂やめましょうと
噂っていうのは相手の悪口
その人がないところで言うことなんですよ
これはもうみっともない性格なんですよ
人の悪口はその人いないところで平気で言う
なんか嘘噂話する人間っていうのは
何かあの汚水道みたいなもんで
まあどこでもこう汚いものばっかし
もう 流しているような感じで
あの東京ではないんだけど
田舎に行くと このあのトイレのあれは運ぶでしょ
あのなんか車が来て それで一旦運んでどこかで処理するんだけど
それもしあの あの あれを開けてずっと
あちこちもう漏らしていっちゃうと
どんなもうちょっ ですかね
世界中汚くなって臭くなっちゃうでしょうに
嘘を言う人は大体そんな嘘じゃなくて
噂を言う人はそんなタイプなんですよ
どこを行っても臭いんです
喋るものっていうのは
だからそういう言葉はやめてくださいと
で 逆にいい言葉 人のいいところね
だけ喋るようにしてくれ
そうすると自分がどこへ行っても
まあ香りがいい人間なんですね
そこで 4番目 無駄話やめなさい
無駄話は頭が悪くなる
時間は無駄 それから終わりがない
いくらでも喋れますから
聞いた人の役にも立ちませんし
喋った人の役にも立ちませんし
ただ時間の無駄だけ それで頭が良くならない
ですから無駄話やめなさいと
それは称号なんですよ
だから何が正しい言葉っていうのは
こんなことは決めることはできません
だからやってはいけない言葉だけ理解しておけば生活しやすいんです
すごく人格が出てくるんです
もう 2つありますけど
全部 3つもセットがあって
で あの 4つ  4番目はこの体の行動なんですね
我々の行うこと やること
やることは全部正しいことをやってくださいという意味なんですけど
何が正しいですかと わからないでしょうに
ですから 例えば道路の掃除するべきかないかとかね
もうわからないんですよ
正しいか ですから そこでやってはいけないことはあるんですね
他人の生命 他の生命を殺すことだけはやめましょう
で それから盗んだりすることをやめましょうと
よこしまない行為をすることをやめましょう
簡単ですよ  3つだけやめてやめればいいんです
行動はまあ自由ですよ
他の行動は自由です その 3つだけ守って行動すると称号なんです
他人の生命を殺すことはもうやめる
たとえ動物であろうが殺さないことにする
物を取ることはね 盗むこともやめる
で  5番目 称名になるんですね
称名っていうのは仕事なんです
人間が何か仕事をしないと
これ正しい命ではありません
この漢字が間違ってるんです
昔から仏教の世界で この漢字が間違ってるんだから
この解説もすごく間違ってるんです
ある人は自分がブッダの生まれ変わりだと言ってね
でもそれも嘘なんですけど
そこでブッダだからもう八正道さ語らないとブッダになりませんだからね
もう人の考え方を盗むなよと言いたい
言いたいんだけどね 自分がブッダだから自分で喋ればいいでしょうに
称名のところ説明すると
むちゃくちゃ これはもう霊魂のことであると
霊魂はちゃんと磨いて綺麗にしなくちゃいけないんだと
科学ではもうわかりませんと
そんなことは だから科学は科学に任せるとかね
まあ病気もいいところですけど
そんな そういう だからそういう
なぜ間違うかというと
これはもうどこかで誰か
この一般人向けに書いた仏教の本でも
ちょっとずつだけ読んでもう言うことだから
専門家でも誰でもないし
だから中国でこの称名という字を入れちゃったんだから
その字はちょっと間違ってるんですよ
アージワっていうのはライフスタイルであって
生き方なんです パーリ語のアージュ
サンスクリット語のアージュもそういうことなんです
何をして生きているんですか？ということで
だから称名の字は間違ってます
だから どんな言葉がいいんでしょうかね
ライフスタイルというかね
一般的に言えば仕事って意味なんですけどね
何をして食べてるんですかと
何をして生活をつなげているんですかと
何をして自分の命をつなげているんですかということなんですね
ですから 本当はまあ 生活とかね
でも小生活はちょっとあまりこの
音はね あまり綺麗じゃないし
まあ簡単な英語で言えば
このライフスタイルという
だから英訳はライトリビングと英訳するんですよ
これはライトリビングと訳するんです
だから生活なんですよ
で 人間っていうのは何かをして生きていなくちゃいけない
動物もそうでしょうね
仕事なく生きていられませんよ
だから生命には まあ餌はね
口に自動的に入るとかね
はないんです 動物にしても仕事をしないと
だからこの世の中で生まれたものは
誰でも何か仕事をして食べているんです
それは避けられないんです
で まあヒヨコだったらね
口に自動的に入りますけど
赤ちゃんだったら まあ一応自動的に食べ物は口に入りますけど
それ以外はもう無理ですよ
なんとかしないと ですから
この正しいことをしなさいと
この生活として正しい仕事をしなさいというと
どんな仕事を正しいんでしょうかね
これまた決められなくなります
ですから やめる仕事 こういう仕事だけはやめてくださいと
仕事のために殺すこと
仕事のために盗むこと
仕事のためによくない行為をすること
それだけやめてくださいと
他の仕事は自由ですよ
収入さえ入れば ですから
このショーで言ったこと
同じことを仕事にもするなよと
まあ時々いますからね
まあ別に自分個人では人を殺したりはしませんだけど
仕事上は殺すと いるでしょうに
それはやめてほしいと
それで生き方 はっきりしていますよ
それもわかりやすく やりやすくお釈迦様はおっしゃいますよ
これやりなさいではなくて
これやめなさいと そうすると把握できるでしょうに
やりなさいということを言っちゃうと
どこまで言えばいいんでしょうかね
時代によってそれは変わっちゃうでしょうね
もしお釈迦様がちゃんとこの農業をやって生活しなさいと言ったならば
今の時代どうしますかね
そうするとお釈迦様の教えが時代遅れになっちゃうんです
仏教徒の仕事は農業であるべきですよと何とかおっしゃったならば
そういうアホなことをお釈迦様しません
だから 今の時代にもぴったし合うように
この仕事だけはやめなさいと
３つぐらいやめてもらう
他のことは自由です ですから
車の工場でも飛行機の工場でも
普通の会社でも証券会社でも仕事はできます
どこでも でも人生命を殺すことはできません
盗むことはできません
証券会社で仕事をしているんだからといって
もう本当はもう損するのにも知っている上に
お客さんを騙して やっぱりいいですよ
いいですよ 投資してくださいと言ってね
人のお金を取ったりして
それで会社は儲かるんだけど
あの人はもう全部もう倒産するとか
そういうこともやらせてるでしょうね
それは盗みですね そういうことをしないで
まあ正直に頑張ればいいんですね
それで生き方 で 次にものすごく大きな問題が出てくるんです
なんとか生きていられます
でも証券が出てくると
全ては虚しいでしょう
結局はどんな生き方をしたっても
大したろくな生き方じゃないですよ
音楽家になったっても
まあ医者になったっても
弁護士になっても 普通のサラリーマンになったってもね
まあ結局はまあ年取ったら退職
もう退職して それでまあコソコソと死ぬだけのことなんですよ
で たとえ日銀の総裁であろうともね
退職しちゃったらもう何のこともない
まあエンジェルだから
このどこかで 60 歳まで仕事見つかるかもしれませんだけど
でも年取ってくるとボロボロでね
判断能力もなくて あまり役に立ちません
だから この 90 歳になってもできる仕事っていうのはね
たとえボケてもできる仕事っていうのは一つしかないんですよ
世の中って政治家になること
だから人間いい加減でもそういうことでしょう
政治家になる資格っていうのはないんです
でも 普通のちっぽけな会社に入るためには
やっぱり履歴書を持って行って
いろいろ資格を見せて
試験を受けて 面接を合格して
行儀よく振り回っていろいろ苦労しないと採用してもらわないんですよ
で 頭がおかしくて 精神的な病気でない限りは
普通の正気の人間だったら
選挙に出られます まあ嘘言ったらダメですけど
ない学歴を書いたりしちゃうとダメなんですけど
そうでない限りは大丈夫です
それで退職はなし でも一番大事な仕事ですよ
面接なしでよくもそういう仕事に
国の全責任持ってるとこなんですけど
そちらには資格は要りませんというんだから
大体人類っていうのはいい加減ですよ
それは日本も同じで 外国も同じなんですよ
政治家になるために何の資格も要りません
それはシンガポールだけ厳しいんです
大統領選挙なんかに出る場合は
ちゃんとその自分がふさわしいという免許をもらわないと
あの自分も投票が あの何といいますか
選挙に出るんだということは
選挙管理局に出せないんです
選挙管理局を出す場合はもう一つ証明書が必要なんです
国の大統領になるぐらいの能力ある人であると
それはチェックする機関があります
厳しく調べるんです 財産はありますかと
それくらいの学問的能力がありますか？人格がありますかと
厳しく調べて  じゃああんたいいですよ
選挙に出ると その紙をもらう
その国だけ 他の国ではもう誰でもいいんです
ですから まあまあ  それはまあいい加減な話で言ったんだけど
あんまり関係ない話で
まあそれは人間の判断力というのはいかに無責任でいい加減だということでしょうにね
どんな世の中を見ても
それは置いといて とにかくこの人間っていうのはね
どんな仕事をしたっても
やがてはもう何もない
例えばお仏さんにしたってもね
本当に真剣 真面目にもう頑張ったんだけどね
すごい必死になって もう頑張った
すごい立派な方なんですけど
ぱっと病気になってしまっちゃってね
もうすごい過労でね で
それでもう倒れちゃって
もうわからない 今どんな調子かと
だからもう命懸けなんですね
仕事にしたっても それに怖くなって今何人か辞めるんだけど
今更気づいたってもね
本当は痛かったみたいですね
ボロボロボケてしまっても
やっぱりあのケース見たらすごくショックを受けちゃってね
まあやめた方がいいんだというふうな
もう遅いんだけど やっぱりそういうのは本当に能力ある若者に
あの元気な時ね 任せた方がいいの
一番きつい仕事でしょうし
たとえ国の総理になったっても
まあそういうことでもうなんのことなく虚しく終わっちゃうんですよ
音楽家 音楽家になっても売れる
売れるか売れないか 歌を作って出してももう売れるか分からないしね
結局そんな人生でいいんでしょうか
タレントさんなんだか人生見ちゃうとね
もう全くおかしいでしょうに
振り回されて 人形みたいに言われることばっかしやって
だからすごく虚しいということを感じちゃう
弁護士になったって 毎日毎日毎日
そういう何かのトラップ
どうすればいいかと同じものを調べたり
調べたりする 虚しく感じるんですよ
証券があったら でも仏教はそれはすごくいいことだと
やることに執着する必要ないんだと
すべて虚しいんだと言うんですよ
そこで虚しく感じたら
どうしますかね？仕事できますかね？例えば設計士がいて
すごく苦労して何か設計すると
それを自分の会社に持っていったら
あ これはダメねと一言言ったら
またここら辺 ここら辺全部直して
ここを直して またやり直すと言ったら
この人はまた徹夜して
また二 三週間苦労しなくちゃいけない
あれは全部パーになっちゃうでしょうに
あるいは何人かに頼んでやらせた時は
自分の計画は全部そのままボツになる場合もあるでしょうに
そうすると仕事をやる気がなくなっちゃうんです
何でも虚しいんだから
でもそれは事実だからしょうがないんですよ
たとえ仕事のやる気がなくなっても
例えば一生懸命ものすごい張り切っちゃって子供を育てても
子供は大きくなっちゃったら出て行っちゃうんですよ
老夫婦だけ家にも残っちゃうんです
面倒を見ようともしない子供たちは
そんなことは最初から考えちゃうとやる気がなくなっちゃうんです
でも お釈迦様は最初からそれ考えておけと
結局は無意味ですよと
子供育てても 最初は結果はゼロと
何も得られませんと そうすると虚しくなる
やる気も消えるはずですが
お釈迦様は幸せの道を教えているのです
次のステップはそういうステップなんです
はい こちら こちらです
全部 次にお釈迦様はすごい安らぎを教えちゃうんです
こんなくだらんものにとらわれて
どうせ消えるものをつかまろうとつかまろうと思っても
このシャボン玉をつかまって家に持っていくというのはそんな無意味でしょうに
すべてはシャボン玉やと思っちゃう方がお釈迦様はいい言葉をおっしゃってますよ
この泡だよと全部 この泡の世界っていうのは
つかまろう握ろうと思っても泡はじけていっちゃいますから
結局バカ見るだけなんです
家族も会社も仕事も もう何でももうただ泡だけなんです
シャボン玉です そこを理解してほしい
そうすると 理解しなかったらシャボン玉を握ろうと思った人が結局悲しくなってしまっちゃうんです
最初からそれを理解する
そうすると まず言ったような感じで
なんとなくまあやったって意味がないんではないかと
結婚したっても幸せになりくはないし
子供がいたっても幸せになりくはないし
仕事をやっても幸せになりくはないし
虚しいし苦しいし まあ嫌だと
ではどうすればいいかという疑問に出会うんですよ
それで 6番精進 やっぱりこのやることに意味があるんですよ
怠けることには苦しみがあるんですよ
子供を育てることに意味があるんです
子供が大きくなって親の面倒を見てくれるんだという
あれは無意味 あれは馬鹿を見ること
ただ 今こういうことをやらなくちゃいけないと
そこで励むこと 仕事をすることに意味があるんですよ
したんだからといって会社に褒めてくれるとかね
給料が上がってくれるとか
それはないんです 会社は決して私をリストラにしてくれないんだとかね
可愛がってくれる それは大嘘で
でもやるものはすごくしっかりとやることには喜びがあるんです
一番苦しいなのはこの怠けることですね
やる気がないと だから何やっても結果は同じでしょうし
だからそんなことを考える必要ないんですよ
張り切って仕事をしたんだからといって
会社はもうお金で計算するんだからね
この人は簡単にクビにすることができるんだよとわかったらすぐ捨てますから
そこを最初から考えて
やっぱりどうせクビになるんだからって仕事をしないと早くクビになっちゃうんです
5年目にクビになる人は 1年目でクビになっちゃいますから
で アメリカだったらあるでしょうし
例えば子供の面倒 どうせ子供は他人だからと
法律的には だから面倒見なくてもいいんだといい加減にしちゃったら
法律で子供を持っていっちゃうんです
親の権利はないと だからそれもまたいいわけじゃないですよ
ですから 子供は大きくなって
もう親を不幸しようが
親の面倒を見ようが見なくそうどうでもいいことで
やることに意味がある
ですから 常に常に精進しなくちゃいけない
という精進ということ
やることはしっかりやりましょうと
文句言われないように
だからよくみんな言うでしょ？褒めてくれません
認めてくれません あれは間違っている考え方なんですね
褒めてくれる必要はないんです
認めてもらう必要もないんです
自分の分担はちゃんとやっておく
はい 勝手にしなさい それは向こうの世界だから
自分には管理できません
それで働く分は 仕事をする分は
努力する分は 自分には楽しみは感じられます
充実感は感じられます
だからみんなこのスポーツとかなさってるそうでしょ
いろいろ健康のためとかね
あれは私はあれよりは何か体力使って仕事をした方がもっと充実感感じるだろうと思いますね
例えば 何時間も何か機械の中で何か運動したりしたっても面白くないと思いますよ
それよりは 自分住んでいるところは全部探検するんだと
小さな道路から大きな道路をどこからでも歩いてみると
そうすると何か知識さえでも来るでしょうね
自分住んでいる街は全部探検終わったと
で 次の日からは電車でも2つ駅一つ駅を置いて
そこら辺また探検してみるとか
いろいろ役に立つことがありますね
で 体力作った方は店で買い物したら
それは宅急便で送ってもらうんじゃなくて
じゃあ持っていくんだと
その日で品物戻るんだからね
これはもう手が痛くてきついかもしれませんだけど
自分の運動にもなります
そうやって運動の場合でも意味のある方向へ持っていけばね
面白いだろうと思いますけどね
じゃあそれは正精進 それはそこら辺で終わって
で  7番目正念 正念というのは
この瞬間瞬間 物事を変化しているんだ
変化しているんだということをキャッチすることなんですよ
それですっごく面白くなるんです
瞬間瞬間 何でも変化している
それをキャッチするんです
そうすると これ いろんなものにとらわれている心が
何にもとらわれなくなっちゃうんですよ
なんかすごく安定してくるんです
心がすごく落ち着いてくるんです
それで 8番目 精進という心の混乱は全部消えちゃう
消えちゃって ものすごく充実感と喜びを感じられるようになる
それは外の影響ではないんです
いい仕事をしたんだからすごい幸せ
そんなくだらないことじゃないんです
そういう原因と関係なく
心は統一になっちゃって
心は何のことなく すごく喜びと充実感を感じるようになってくるんです
だから すごくこの幸せっていうのは
みんな一人も感じたことはないんですよ
みんな幸せっていうのは一時的なインチキなんです
この心が安らぎを感じるんです
世の中で何が起きても
地震が起きても 火事が起きても
会社がリストラになっても
心ではすごく充実感と安らぎ感を感じるんです
それを正定というんです
だから正見で暗くなるわけじゃないんです
そのしっかりした道なんですね
八正道は だから大変な道で
だから判断する場合は中道でやりましょうというのは単純なことでもないんです
真ん中の道でもないんです
まずは頭をしっかりしてもらって
それから言葉を考え方をコントロールしてもらって
それから言葉と行動と仕事はちゃんと整理しておいて
それから精神的な心の充実感
安らぎをもらう それは自分のもの
子供を幸せにしてあげたでも
それは子供のもの 自分のものじゃないんです
それは自分の幸せということになります
そういうことは判断決断する仏教の道なんです
結構きついかもしれませんだけど
そこでお話はこういう言葉で終了したいんです
大体我々は生きている間では
こういうモットーを作った方がいいんですね
私は清らかに生きています
やはり汚れた生き方はしませんと
まあちょっと英語でメモったんだから
なかなかいきなり日本語訳できなく
自分の生き方 とにかく清らかな生き方をしますと
あれ間違いを起こしません
汚れたことはしませんとと決める
それから 私は今までも悪いこと
いけないこと 後で後悔することはしてもないし
これからも後で後悔すること
悪いことはしませんと
しっかりする 私はもう後悔することだけは
悪いことだけはしませんと
よく言えば I did not do not and will not do evil things.というふうな言葉になりますけどね
間違っていることだけはしません
これからしっかり自信必要ですよ
いろいろ誘惑されますからね
だからたとえ誘惑でも
これは間違ってるんだからね
やばいんだからね 私はやりませんと
今までやったこともないんですよと
なんで今更と 例えば子供たちをね
まあ麻薬なんかに誘惑するでしょう
だから子供たちしっかりしてるんだと
今まで使ったことはない
そんな変なものはね やばいものはやりませんよと
はっきりと言った方がいい
その時はいくら凶暴になってもいいんですよ
正しい方法だから だから腰抜はよくない
やっぱり正しい生き方っていうのはかなりきつくて凶暴なんですよ
私はやりませんと それで悪いことは絶対的にやめて
この自信つける 生きる自信を
その時はこの他人に批判されないようにということもありますけど
あまり相手に当てにしない方がいいんですよ
バカどももいっぱいいるんだからね
時々悪いことをしない人も批判する場合あるでしょうに
ですから 相手の批判なんかはね
みんなもうろくな人間ではないんだから
だからね まあ政治家にはもうもう退職もないんだから
そういうぐらいの判断する社会だから
我々生きてる世界っていうのは
だから人の批判はね あまり相手にしないで
人を何と言おうとも 私が間違っていることはしませんと
で その点で凶暴になってもいい
凶暴っていうのは 自分の生き方をずっと通ってもらうと
別に凶暴になって人に暴力振るうことではないんです
それからそういうふうに
最後の言葉 ３つしかないんですけど
私は決して悪いことをしないで
きちんと正しく生きているんだからといって
だからといって私はすごい大胆な
素晴らしい とてつもない人間でもありませんと
単なる生き物で人間でよと
ただみんなと一緒に生きているだけやと言っておいて
自分のエゴを消す 例えば
ものすごく頑張って みんなにいいことをして頑張っていても
まあまあたまたまやっただけですよ
大したことないんだと
というふうな思って 自分のエゴを消す
例えばしっかり頑張って何か本作ったりする
今 本しか頭に浮かばないんですけど
本作ったりする 結構いいもの
自分がすごい真面目に頑張っちゃったんで
いいものできたりする
それでどうだい？どうだい
これはね これは私が作ったんだよとかね
そういう威張りようになっちゃうと
次にできなくなっちゃうんです
たとえ人がそれを褒めたて
まあまあまあまあ そこそこやっただけでも
大したことはないんだと正直にそう思うことなんだよ
本当はもっと立派なものをできたはずですよと言って
自分の心のエゴを消してもらう
例えば 私の話をたくさん
私の例を言うならば たくさんの人が聞いて
よく仏教を理解して人生は幸せになったとする
私は威張ってはいけません
いえ 大したことはないんだと
みんなよくできて よく話を聞いて真面目に頑張ったんだから起きた結果だよと
私は何もやったことじゃないんだと
私は知ったことじゃないんだと
それは皆様の努力の結果でしょうと
かえってこちらの方が感謝したいんだというふうに思うこと
私が感謝したいんだと
そうやってエゴを消す
その３段階で生きていれば
この物事について白か黒かという決まる決める問題が解決するだろうと思います
どうもこの辺で話を終了させていただき
ありがとうございます